I'm tired of old white murder yeah man
it's getting really old we need some
slaw cat knocking speaking of crazy [ __ ]
like that I was in Vegas for New Year's
like a fool
oh really yeah for what uh you know
little Dickie the rapper do you know him
yeah yes yeah yeah he's a friend and he
was performing there okay and we went
there and my lady and a friend and
another friend of ours they wanted to
see Gwen Stefani do her like one of her
last shows so I bucked up and I'm when
saw Gwen Stefani and then I went and saw
my boy little dick hold on
I didn't block up and go see Winstead I
wasn't no I wasn't really sleeve amezo
no call you back yeah she did spider
well she did yeah of course
I love good I love Gwen Stefani but I
wasn't like I wasn't like gotta see her
on New Year's Day get 40 songs it's like
what are these songs well then she's got
some cuts he does she's got some cuts is
Gwen Stefani the lady from The Voice -
yes that's cool she's married to the
dude that's on the voice no way Adam
Levine nope Blake Shelton Blake Shelton
oh really did he come out nah he didn't
he was back drinking from sure dude I'm
[ __ ] out it's like 30 steps and do a
hit I know I'm mad I was mad I was mad I
was so then what then you and your boy
you're out with a little dickie in Vegas
then we went out a little Dicky in Vegas
yeah we had a good time then we ended up
at the chainsmokers hotel room do you
know they are yeah that band yeah yeah
you're extremely band dropping right now
yeah well I did what I did and how big
was their hotel room as funny wasn't as
big as I thought it was gonna be really
yeah cuz they were like we wanted the
chainsmokers party I was it's gonna be
[ __ ] wild as [ __ ] I was amped on the
bus I was lit up I was on the stripper
pole doing my thing everybody's laugh
and we get there and I'm like James ball
goes Oh duh room we got VIP DUP there
and everyone's kind of quiet they had a
tray of dessert out I was like this
ain't it Wow
when you say dessert he talking drugs
and stuff like that now they had real
that ice cream ice cream and milk shakes
I'm talking about some snow I know there
was no drugs
I couldn't believe there's no drugs dude
I'd let somebody fart a gram into my
veins if a smoker party dude whatever it
was not what I thought it was gonna be
Wow there was just like a and everyone
the liquor was like gone it was kind of
like low-key it was just super low-key
everyone's trying to be cool I don't
know if you're been of these parties
that like yeah everyone's trying so hard
to be cool no one's having fun anymore
oh yeah you know by the way nobody ate
the ice cream but me and my buddy
California's Los Angeles yeah we ate the
ice cream it was a table it was a table
filled with ice cream like individual
bowl trap bowls of ice cream nobody
touched it me Jeff all over it no
chocolate chip I was dipping in
everything really both you guys are
different of the same one hell yeah oh
Jeff we got tested together I wouldn't
do that with them but the chainsmokers
were there and the dude was talking to
deke and they were chatting it up and he
kept throwing eyes at us cuz we kept
eating ice cream mm-hmm and he was kind
of giving me like wow that was kind of
well do you see a ginger [ __ ]
thumbing through your dairy [ __ ] you
gotta shut him down
who let the slapping on in to eat ice
cream yeah there's old boys came for
some ice cream and I skip out there's
old limericks about that yeah there is a
leprechaun ice cream yeah I see I was in
his [ __ ] ice cream and then we I was
bummed out we had to get out of there I
was like I gotta go gamble man this is I
don't like Hollywood parties and this is
no disrespect to them I don't like
Hollywood parties where no one's having
fun yeah it's like why are we almost no
Hollywood though it's the eights
it's to look like there's fun but yeah
yeah yeah it's why the ED 1:30 a.m.
Hollywood shuts down it's like it's like
let's just get the appearance that
there's joy here yeah and then get these
images out on the rest of America
usually people go to Vegas to have fun
yeah just were a lot of the fun happen
if they live there I'm sure those guys
live they do a residency I'm sure they
[ __ ] live in those soldiers live
there oh yeah oh wow they live there in
here cuz they do they do a bunch of
those guys they do that yeah they go out
every weekend or whatever yeah so they
kind of live they live there for four
days that's three days yeah I I got
stuck in the Vegas strip on New Year's
one time and the stripper like walking
in the street yeah at New Year's I was
trying to get to my friends and I took
like a wrong way to wine there's
literally there was a million people
stuff there was a million people in the
street nowhere to walk everybody
drinking those huge [ __ ] [ __ ] yes
dude one guy I was running around here
this big thing and for like a buck he
put it around your waist you could piss
into it dude that's smart
yeah that's a really smart business out
of the blue this is on the strip really
yeah guy was pooping on the strip
dude I saw a guy in India one time
pooping get hit by a [ __ ] taxi mid
poop yeah did he live I don't know Brian
will stay around after that yeah you got
a good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw I
mean it was okay but the next video you
could watch could be
better what if you watch a video right
now that changes your life well you
could watch this one or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one